es gibt also scheinbar kein ende in
pflicht lockdown omikron was da alles
auf uns zukommt und wie man damit
umgehen sollte darüber wollen wir jetzt
mit dem grünen oberbürgermeister von
tübingen entsprechende boris palmer der
für klartext bekannt ist hallo herr
palmer schönen guten morgen
sagen wir so viel gehörte über unicom
über die neue variante die uns große
sorgen macht und gleichzeitig haben wir
das versprechen gestern bekommen von
karl lauterbach es wird vor weihnachten
kein harten lockdown geben kann man
dieses versprechen aus ihren augen
überhaupt jetzt zu diesem zeitpunkt
abgeben
weil es so kurz vor weihnachten ist kann
man das vermutlich aber ich bin trotzdem
erstaunt weil karl lauterbach bevor
minister war ja immer man die
drastischste variante für seine
politischen statements zur grundlage
gemacht hat das tut er jetzt offenkundig
nicht sondern er wählt er ein
bedächtiges vorgehen ich bin jedenfalls
der meinung dass wir jetzt schon so wie
london sie erlebt sehr ernst nehmen
müssen und wenn man dort die daten
anschaut dann steht zu befürchten dass
im januar dann nächste locker und kommt
und lässt ja nicht mal reichen würde um
die intensivstation vor überlastung zu
schützen deswegen bin ich der meinung
dass jetzt endlich vorgezogen werden
musste lief den februar nichts mehr
gegen omikron die müsste fortkommen da
haben sie ihre meinung also geändert
omikron kann ich vor vier wochen noch
nicht ich habe anfang november für eine
impfpflicht für über 60-jährige geworden
die über 60 jährigen sind diejenigen die
in allererster linie intensivbetten
benötigen wenn sie sich infizieren aber
die daten aus london die es jetzt gibt
die zeigen ein exponentielles wachstum
eine verdoppelung etwa alle zwei tage
wenn wir annehmen bei uns wird sich noch
alle vier tage verdoppeln weil wir eine
höhere booster haben dann hätten wir
trotzdem wie die januar 250.000
infektionen am tag und das ist es nur
die übertragung der londoner ergebnisse
der letzten zwei wochen auf deutschland
also nicht irgendeine labor frage und
dann bin ich der meinung wenn so ein
szenario droht dann muss man handeln
jetzt nicht wegen eines doktors vor
weihnachten der bringt bionics noch
nichts
aber für den januar muss jetzt
entschieden werden was zu tun ist
das bedeutet dann nach weihnachten alles
dichtmachen wie soll dieser lockt dann
aussehen
zugänglicher ich finde der lok dann ist
die schlechteste aller möglichkeiten wir
hätten von dem jahr schon eine
nachverfolgung sap konstruieren können
die man jetzt aktivieren könnte die
omikron fälle so sicher nach erfolg dass
man die abschotten können haben wir aber
nicht darum wir könnten die impfpflicht
schon lange im bundestag haben in
städten wo die nur darüber debattiert
meiner meinung nach sollte der bundestag
jetzt wieder zusammenkommen ihr müsst
ihr wahrscheinlich die nationale notlage
wieder anerkennen andernfalls sind die
länder nicht ausreichend handlungsfähig
über weihnachten und richtig wäre sie
würde so lange zusammen sitzen bis die
impfpflicht beschlossene sache ist denn
dann könnte man bis mitte januar die
drei millionen ungeimpften über 60
impfen und das würde wahrscheinlich
ausreichen um das schlimmste für den
intensivstationen zu verhindern selbst
wenn omikron sich bei uns so schnell
ausbreitet wie sind london der fall war
mit blick auf die schulen was ist die
repo klose könnte es da auch wieder zu
schulschließungen kommt
immer auf der grundlage der kurve die
london zeigt nochmal dieses
exponentielles wachstum alle zwei bis
drei tage wird der lockdown im januar
bei uns so schlimm zahlen müssen so hart
sagen müssen wir ohne impfung gewesen
ist und er wird wahrscheinlich auch
ziemlich lange andauern müssen weil am
mikro dermaßen infektiös ist in london
jedenfalls dass ich wirklich fast jeder
anstieg wir haben das gerade auch im
interview mit ihrer korrespondenten
gesehen und wenn eben zu viele menschen
gleichzeitig krank werden dann in das
krankenhaus system dem nicht stand auch
wenn die verläufe insgesamt wesentlich
milder wären was zu hoffen ist als bei
der delta variante deswegen noch mal
mein plädoyer sofort geimpft licht und
falls jetzt jemand sagt das kann doch
niemand durchsetzen es geht sogar ganz
einfach bei der masse nicht gibt es
keinerlei probleme da geht es nur mit
kita-platz oder unschuldig man könnte
die pensionszahlungen die rentenzahlung
oder eben den zutritt zum arbeitsplatz
abhängig machen von der vorlage eines
nachweises bis spätestens 15 januar oder
müssten alle bescheid sicher es gebe
dann kaum noch im verweigerung also ich
weiß noch mal zusammen herr palmer sagt
ein harter
langanhaltender lockdown und eine
impfpflicht und alles so schnell wie
möglich inklusive schulschließung
ich sage wahrscheinlich kommt zum harten
langanhaltenden lockdown wenn die
londoner erfahrungen auf deutschland
übertragbar sind weil wir die
impfpflicht schaffen werden aber
wichtiger wäre es jetzt sofort die
impfpflicht einzuführen dann wäre
möglicherweise dieser hatte lange
anhalten der lok gar noch von mike batt
immer unter der voraussetzung dass wir
in london sehen ist auf deutschland
übertragbar wisst ihr aber nicht warum
es bei uns wesentlich anders verlaufen
sollte von welchen zeitraum gehen sie da
aus wenn sie sagen langer lockdown
bei dieser stark anhaltenden welle würde
die welle relativ lange viel zu hoch
sagen und deswegen müsste man relativ
lange im lockdown bleiben haben
überhaupt die intensivstationen wieder
in einen normalen zustand zurück zu
bekommen und dann wären locker und wie
im letzten jahr ziemlich wahrscheinlich
zwei bis anhin hatte ist die dauer die
man dann so eine welle aushalten muss
leider sozusagen um durch die infektion
zu erreichen dass ich fast alle dann
immunisiert haben omikron scheint so
ansteckend zu sein dass die ungeimpften
in diesem winter mit sicherheit geimpft
werden nur leider eben durch die
infektion karl lauterbach hat das
gestern bei uns hierbei die richtigen
fragen sehr bildlich sehr plastisch
zusammengefasst wäre noch mal ran
also es wird ja immer gesagt wir müssen
lernen mit dem virus zu leben das höre
ich immer wieder aber wenn man offen ist
also mit dem virus wirklich gut zu leben
wird uns nur gelingen wenn der
allergrößte teil der bevölkerung geimpft
ist also ist so sie können sie also sie
können nicht also mit einem tiger als
haustier leben das wird nicht gehen
ein tiger als haustier das wird nicht
gehen japaner würden sie es auch so
geschrieben
hat er wahrscheinlich recht wobei mir
ist jetzt wichtig wäre dass der tiger
lauterbach sprechen wo es war wie
gewohnt mit klaren worten herzlichen
dank für das interview